okay everyone welcome to this
presentation on the Delta Surge from
orderflows decom my name is Michael
Volos I'm the founder and Trader at
orderflows thatcomicbookguy
and make lots of money and charge you
$1,000 do for it but you know what if
you just stick around and wait till the
end of the presentation you know I'll
give you the information that you can
just go and download it from my website
for free it runs on N ninja Trader 7
ninja Trader 8 version is is not yet
ready ninja Trader 8 is still in uh beta
you know just a brief example this is a
cell here okay this one didn't work out
you know but here you got to write off
this sort of Swing lowish area you got a
nice buy and it's a nice move you know
65 it's almost a 10-point
move anyway uh before I get started and
talk about anything a brief disclaimer
this presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation a buy
or sell a Futures Contract or make any
other type of investment decision future
trading contain substantial risk and is
not for every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and only those which sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future
results so the tools that I'm going to
use in this presentation are the order
flows Trader which is a volume footprint
chart that I developed but it's more
than just a volume footprint chart
there's a lot of analysis that's going
on in there and it's easy to understand
analysis it's not stuff that you know
you really got to sit there and scratch
your head and and try and figure out the
Delta surge indicator which is what
presentation is about and the ninja
Trader trading platform again you can
download this for free go to www.
ninjatrader do.com it's a great tool for
trading and back testing and and
charting um you know I said and and it's
free they have a paid version which is
great if you also want to
trade you can open an account with them
and since you have a a paid version of
their software you can get
extremely extremely competitive low
commission r rates for futures
contracts okay so you again the Delta
surge is its free indicator and if you
stick around to the end of the
presentation I'll show you how I can
download it from my website for free
what does it do it measures increases in
Delta either positive increases which
show Traders basically piling into the
market or negative increases which often
indicates Traders getting out of the
market often times you know once the
market is dropping people can't get out
fast enough and you just see it you know
building and building and building the
Delta surge will run on the orderflows
trader chart as well as a normal hard
chart I know some people are scared of
trading a footprint chart and that's one
of the reasons why we developed it to
also work on a normal bar chart so how
does it look it looks like
this here you have this high high of the
day right here 74 you got a sell signal
here know you can get short somewhere
anywhere between
6869 you know it makes a nice fivepoint
move shortly thereafter how does it look
on a bar chart this is how it looks
you've got a nice uh High here gives a
sell indication you know I'll be honest
all the charts don't look as pretty as
this I'm just you know showing you there
there chart I I'll show you where it
doesn't work but anyway uh let's get on
to you know what is Delta as applied to
order flow well it's the difference
between aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers you know sometimes when you hear
the term Delta you think of options okay
orderflow Delta is completely different
than options
Delta what's an aggressive buyer well
it's a Trader who buys the offer what's
an aggressive seller it's a Trader who
sells at the
bid Market orders are considered
aggressive you know
for for a market
to
move you there has to be a trade right
and there has to be every trade has a
buyer and seller again the Market's not
going to move because there're more
buyers and sellers no that's that's
that's crazy yeah for every buyer there
is a seller the reason the markets move
up is because buyers are being
aggressive and they're are buying the
offer that's what's causing the market
to move up because they buy enough of
the offer that the price moves higher
everything that was on offer has been
bought and now you're looking at the
next price so say the market is N9 bid
at 10 and there's 20 Lots offered at 10
someone comes in and buys 21 they bought
all the 20 that were there now the
market is big bid at 10 it's 10 bid at
11 that's how the markets move higher is
when people start buying the offers and
markets move lower because sellers are
selling the
bid you know okay you know some people
will I'm sure somebody will comment and
say oh you know that's that's that's not
true well there are other ways you mean
people could pull their offers could be
no offer yeah that could cause the
market to go higher because nobody wants
to sell okay but in in normal market
conditions there's generally always a
bid and an offer you know you don't have
to get all extreme and send me nasty
emails and saying that it's wrong I mean
come on trade it under normal conditions
there's a bid and there's an offer I
understand that there's going to be
times where you know people like to play
games and pull their offer or pull their
bid you know that that happens okay but
generally there's always you know now
that it's all on screen there's a bid
there's an offer there's people's jobs
they have to you know market makers they
have to always provide a bid in the
offer that people can trade against so
Delta is the difference between
aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers so you know there are many ways
Traders can try and hide their
intentions their aggressiveness in the
market But ultimately their actions will
show up in the volume and more precisely
in the Delta you know people can try and
pick away at an offer you know you know
say there's 200 on the offer and
someone's got 500 to buy they might buy
a 100 you know they don't want to turn
it bid they might buy 50 and wait for
more offers to come in and keep buying
it like that it will show up in there
now while Mo while Market orders are
aggressive limit orders are generally
considered passive since Traders are
waiting for the market to come to them
however there are instances when limit
orders can be viewed as aggressive
action but that won't show up in the
Delta as aggressive action it'll just
it'll show up as a normal U you know
normal volume traded on the bid actually
show up opposite but an aggressive
I guess what the point I'm trying to
make is you know there are instances and
the main instance is an iceberg order
not an normal Iceberg order but say
someone's got 5,000 snps to buy and
they're going to Iceberg it and show 100
at a time you know yeah they're being
aggressive because they don't want to I
mean they got a lot to buy but they're
not showing at all now that's not to say
you know they can start moving it up but
they're holding the market there you
know that's you know that's borderline
you know if anything I consider that
passive aggressive
they're not showing their intention I
they're showing it for people that are
watching the order flow you can see it
you can see that this big Iceberg there
supporting the
market but it's not an aggressive action
in the term of lifting the offer I mean
they're there supporting the market you
know usually on the way up you you you
know people don't really necessarily
work icebergs on the way down trying to
support the market if someone wants to
support a following Market they'll just
show everything okay you know just
briefly briefly real quick you know a
background on me for those you know that
are new to watching my videos those that
don't know
me I've spent you know basically 20
years on the institutional Futures
Trading side you know eight years of JP
Morgan four years with Cargill three
years with cmer bank two years with EDF
man on the commodi trading site and you
know so I've been around big orders my
entire life you know I'm not someone
that's just conceptual ing things you
know in the basement on a weekend okay
these are based on my
experiences of
trading with you know with real money
you know and and big money so I I know
what it's like to be aggressive at times
in the market I I know it's time to try
and support the market I I know what
it's like to try and hold the market up
so you can get it to close at a certain
price or push the market down because
you need it to close below a certain
price you know those things happen in
the markets okay and sometimes all it
takes is is a little bit of a push what
the Delta surge does you know it it's
it's a way of reading the aggressiveness
in the market okay and yes I have traded
with this okay I I spent a lot of time
trading Commodities in my career among
other
things and you know people always ask
you know what does order flow work
better on does it work better on
Commodities work better on
financials honestly it works good if not
great on any auction Market in the sense
that you know whether it's bean oil
whether it's soy meal whether it's corn
or whether it's Dax whether it's Euro
stocks whether it's &ps NASDAQ you'll
see a lot of charts and you'll see the
same I'm looking at the same thing
because the same Concepts hold true you
know it's not something that's
curve-fitted where it's the crude oil
Trader where it only works on crude oil
I mean you know that's very very limited
you know I mean trading is
not a red light green light system I
mean some people like to come to the
markets thinking oh if I could just have
a system that would tell me when it's
green buy when it's red sell well that's
not trading you know trading is is being
able to make decisions understanding
what you're seeing happening in the
market and and tradeoff of
it okay so sorry I digressed back to the
topic uh where can you see the Delta
well right now you need an orderflow
chart you you don't necessarily need
mine you know if you have an orderflow
chart from
you know another provider or you can
even get them for I'll say for free but
yeah you can get it for 100 bucks you
get the G gy ladder I think it's called
you know go to futures.com you can
become a member there for 100 bucks and
you got a lot of nice indicators there
you can download it there so it's not
free but you got to pay 100 bucks but
it's worth it especially if you're new
to trading um you can learn a lot
there's a lot of interesting people on
that website I don't I don't go there
anymore but uh you know it's an
interesting place you know there's
haters and there's there's nice people
there and okay it doesn't appear yet on
a normal bar chart when I say doesn't
appear yet so I'm sure there somewhere
somewhere down the line someone said hey
you know we should add this feature so
people can see it on a normal bar chart
and it's usually displayed at the bottom
of a chart like here this is a footprint
chart you can see it here boom boom boom
Delta there's Max Delta the main Delta
the number is is this Delta number is
the difference between the buying and
the selling Max Delta
is the most positive Delta was at one
point the Min Delta is the most negative
it was cumulative Delta is the running
Delta for the day it could either be
positive or
negative so what does the Delta surge do
well it measures the expansion in Delta
and why is the expansion important well
it's because it's a sign that one side
either buyers or sellers are showing
their aggressiveness to the market again
you know think of it as you know people
piling into the market okay here's an
example going back to this this a e-
mini chart from uh June 30th you know
we're rallying up boom boom boom boom
hit the high you got a Divergence up
here you got the negative
Delta and what do you see you see 263 -
263 -
474 - 1513 that's your Surge and what
happens is you get a nice fivepoint move
off of it you know what you're seeing
especially you know when it's up near a
high you know as I say always kind to
when you're trading you know I I say
this a lot to people you know I say it a
lot because I I wanted to sink into
people you have to
take what you're seeing in context of
the market you know if you want to sell
ideally you should be looking for a move
to be
ending and then sell you know rather
than you know like here is that soybean
chart right you had to move up then you
get a sell signal yeah that's that's
nice that's what you want to see you
know yeah this one is nice here you know
it it sort of came down bounced up a
little bit continues lower what you
don't really want to see is you have
this big move down here and then you're
getting a signal down here you that's
not going to be as effective as or I say
as effective but not as rewarding as
taking a signal structurally higher on
the
chart okay so again you know the Delta
surge is not designed to be a red light
green light trading
system when Trad you have to take into
account Market context you know is the
market trending or consolidating are you
getting a Buy Signal at a high you know
what's the order flow doing I mean I
can't I'm not going to say you can't buy
at a high because Market can go higher
but that's why if you're trading with an
orderflow chart it'll give you that
extra benefit of analyzing the volume
and seeing you know are people how
aggressive are people really being and
conversely you know when you're getting
a cell signal
you know are you retesting lows are you
going into lows for the first time does
it look like it's capitulation where
everyone the market is just falling out
of bed and everyone's just saying uh you
know get out get out ay you know Trading
Places hey turn those machines back on
know get me out you know is that what's
happening when you're pounding into a
low or not that's why I say you take
things into context I mean that's part
of being a Trader is you have to
understand what the market is doing
and make a
decision so you know I'm going to show
you some examples real quick and you
know different types of charts different
time frames different markets so you can
see it in you know and you make the
decision for yourself if it's something
you could add to your trading or not you
know I'm not saying you you have to use
this but I think it's if you use it it
will give you an insight into the market
that not a lot of people are using I
mean honestly very few people analyze
Delta and make trading decisions off
Delta again is it can you use it as a
standalone I did you know I did use it
as a standalone and you know but back
then my my trading was a bit different
than it is now in the sense and the
markets that I were trading it in you
know weren't as you know it was in the
agricultural markets is where I
developed it and you know agricultural
markets is Market that's dominated by
generally by commercial Traders and
smaller extent it's not dominated by
retail it's dominated by commercials but
you know there's a portion that's retail
driven nowadays there's some you know
there's hedge fund money in it but you
know years ago when I was trading with
this there wasn't all that hedge fund
money in it now sometimes you even more
so with the hedge fund money in it you
know when hedge funds say you know risk
off you know they just get out of
everything all at once and you get you
know five different hedge funds selling
their position out and you know so you
can get some nice moves and trust me
that does show up quite nicely mean you
don't know it when you see the you know
when you see the Delta you don't know
that it's a hedge fund or a commercial
or or you know Joe blow down the street
but you know what's important is is you
don't care what you're looking at is
you're looking at the numbers the Delta
numbers again this is the chart I showed
you earlier e mini 10 range chart you
know this is your high here this was
your high earlier right and you got the
Delta surge just off the high here it
looked like it was starting to turn turn
you know you got the big negative Delta
then what happens it changes in here
right it's met with positive Delta
bigger positive Delta even more bigger
positive Delta and you're taking out the
high okay and what's happening at the
high you got you know you're seeing some
buying imbalances in there you know
that's why I say you know if you have an
orderflow chart it's going to put you
not above but it's going to put you on a
you can see the market what's happening
in the market didn't understand if
you're just look at a bar chart you
don't know what's going on you say oh
yeah we're breaking out the new highs
you but if if for a high to continue you
know you're going to want to see
aggressive buying and you can see it
coming in here you know you're getting
aggressive you know stacked imbalance of
stacked in balances I don't have the
Stacked in balances turned on but you
know you what you're seeing is the
market turning around and shooting
higher with very aggressive buying on a
on bar chart you're not going to see
that this is I think a chart I showed
you earlier as well the 10 range again
you know you have your high Delta
increase 263
47424 1500 and you just see it Delta
even still staying strong all the way
down here so people will say well where
do you get out well you're looking at
some signs yeah you got a positive Delta
in here just cuz you got one bar with
positive Delta doesn't necessarily mean
you got to get out but you know watch
what's happening and you know make the
decision from
there okay this is a what is this is a
15 minute e mini
chart and you have the Delta here you
know it's negative 1100 1900 4,000 and
boom you know this is a 15-minute chart
you know I'm not saying you got to buy
as soon as the bar
opens you know if you want you can work
you know you can work something in there
try and finesse an entry you know but
you know what it do went from 08 up to
18 you I'm not saying you're going to
sell up here you know but this is a mey
portion here you could have got you know
four or five points out of it you know
which is nice you know I mean it is a
10-point move you know so you could at
least should be able to get half of that
I would I would hope if if you're a good
Trader
okay here is again it's a 15-minute
chart now here's a sell signal okay so
we're coming off this High start turning
around come up
here okay going sideways and you get the
signal here now you know honestly I I
would still probably take it because you
know this is a decent move from 06 up to
15 almost 16 it's a 10-point move and
you start to come off okay but what
happens is it turns later and right
before you get up to this area you
seeing this all this buying you know
it's aggressive buying here so you know
even if I was short somewhere in here
you know my stop is just going to be up
here you know so you know maybe I'm
getting short at 11 you know my stop
know 15 if that you know this is a
15-minute chart so you know I'm going to
have big I say bigger stops than normal
but you know my profit targets are going
to be big and my stops might be a little
bit wide but you know what if I see this
buying like this with the Stacked
imbalances coming in here you know I be
you know you got to got to respect that
and you know you have to have a stop in
no matter what so you know this one you
know it started you know it looked like
it was it was working you know if you're
getting short somewhere around
11 you know it's trading down to 08
you're thinking hey this is great you
see this bar then what happens it just
turns around right here and then you run
into this bar and you know it's you're
you're screwed you're going to get
stopped out there there's no way about
it you know I'm showing you winning
trades I'm showing you losing
trades okay this is is again a 15minute
chart and you have your high here start
coming off boom negative Delta 323 79
1000 okay you get the signal again you
could get short somewhere in here you
know 69 you know down to this 60s you
know 64 65
area uh is this okay this is you get e
mini 15minute chart you know cuz you
know people
asking what type of charts can I use you
know I I I tra I'm a swing Trader people
come to me say I'm a swing Trader I have
a a long-term don't say longterm like I
got more than a day time frame view of
the market can I use you know your order
flow indicators on on my charts yes you
can you know I'm I'm just running
through some different examples for you
so you can understand and see and you
know make the decision again you know
this indicator is free I'm not charging
you for it so if if you like it you know
add it to your trading you know give me
credit for it and you know if not then
okay great you know but uh you know so
here's your your high okay you get the
signal here again it's 847
37,000 and you just sort of bounced
around boom you know went up probably
would I don't know if it would stopped
you out if you're getting short
somewhere around 21 you know it's move
up to 23 and 3/4 it's only a three tick
three point stop at this not even three
points it may may not have and you know
then you're coming into the close comes
back down you know I don't know
scratched it I I don't think I would
have gotten stopped out on this you know
usually on on a 15-minute chart I'd have
at least at least a three to four point
stop rather than you know two or three
ticks or two or three points but anyway
you know again you could see how how it
looks and you know you could just T it
on your charts watch it in real time for
a while and see you know if if it's
useful to you okay this is that bean
chart you know okay I showed you a nice
a nice
chart um not many people trade beans but
uh you know I I want to show you on on
different markets a lot of people trade
crude okay so this is an eight range
chart here you got a Buy Signal this one
failed okay this one Buy Signal this one
worked and you know people will you know
I've given people indicators and they'll
send in a chart like this they'll say oh
the indicator sucks look at this it lost
well not every indicator every time it
kicks off is going to give you a win a
big win there's going to be time s you
know unfortun I'll say you know there's
there's two things sure in life death
and taxes the third one should be you
will have trading losses um not every
trade is a winner okay but that's why
you have to have tight stops you have to
have some form of risk management in in
your trading plan okay but are you
willing to risk this you know this is
maybe it's eight range chart so it's
mightbe 10 ticks are you willing to risk
10 ticks to catch a move like this you
know from uh I don't know what that is
2530 up to you know the 80s and '90s
yeah I would take this I would take
trades like this all day long if I know
I could get trades like this as well I
i' want to take all my trades like this
I want to take more like this but you
know what not all are going to look like
this some will look like
that okay again you know this is I put
this example in here because I want to
show
you I talk about taking trades in
context you just have this massive move
down 4610 I don't know if it was higher
up here earlier 46 down down to 45 you
know it's a dollar move in crude and
you're getting the sell signal down here
you just had a massive move and you're
getting a sell signal you know what I
see when I see it like this you know
this is what capitulation is you know
you don't know what capitulation is it's
basically everybody that's long and then
waiting for the market to come back and
you had this massive steep drop off okay
it stops here they're thinking okay hey
maybe I get a bounce and get out and
then the selling comes in and they're
thinking ah we broke down through
here just get me out and then it bounces
back up you know that's that's where
you're seeing it there and you know the
the other thing is you know if I'm
taking a sell signal I don't want to
take it on the back of a of a green
candle you know if I'm taking a sell
signal I expect ideally I'd like the
market the candle to agree with the
position so if I'm got a sell signal I
prefer to see a red
candle you know or if I'm taking a buy I
want to see a green candle
okay so here is is a crude chart again
you know you have this High you know and
you're buying it you know do you want to
be buying the high this is why you got
to look at an orderflow chart and you
know you could decide from there you
know if you think this high is you know
we finally popped up took out the high
from here got through it but you know
what it's still a red candle I said if
you're buying if you're taking a trade
because you got a A Buy Signal you know
you want the candle to be green like you
have it here but this is red you know
again take things in context with what's
happening in the market okay this one
yeah it didn't work out you know started
to you know honestly I would have
scratched this trade if you're got any
skill as a Trader I mean honestly you
know if if you're getting along here and
by here it's not moving yet you get out
you don't hold it until it sells off
like this and then say oh you know this
is terrible well honestly you have all
this time here 8:30 to to 9:00 clock and
the market is going nowhere on
you what it's telling you is get out of
this position and wait for another one
wait for another opportunity you know if
if it hasn't happened in 30 minutes on
an eight range chart you it's going to
be a struggle and then you get a couple
cell signals here you know again this is
a cell and it's it's a green candle so
you know you're probably not interested
to take it you know here's a sell on a
red candle you know and boom you know
from what is that the 30 level down to
you know the 90 level it's a nice 40
points so again are you willing to risk
this for this again I would take
it okay this is a bond chart one minute
chart you again this a one minute chart
so you know it's sort of you know on a
minute level there's a sell here I I
don't remember so I'm not going to talk
about it but you had a couple buys here
you know this one and this one okay and
it's a nice move up from the 20s up to
you know 26 27 28 level
okay here's a one minute chart again you
know this again what I'm talking about
taking things in context you see we just
moved up already had a nice move up you
know consolidate and then you get a nice
another move up
here you know there's a couple ways you
could read this you know people will
think well okay you hit that high you
came off now you're making your SE
second attempt you look for that
breakout I mean there's people that that
trade that way now I honestly I'd have
to look at an orderflow chart and look
at the volume numbers to see
what if I wanted to take this or
not but you know if you took it you you
going have a tight stop you'd be stopped
out okay then a little bit later you got
a sell signal here you know and it say
getting short you know 16 17 you know it
trades down to you know five or six so
again you know you got you got a little
bit of risk here you lost but then you
you've made it back and then some on
this trade you know and I'm not saying
you know you buy it here and you wait
for it to break out you know and you
ignore this you know if you're long here
and you're still in it by this time and
you got the sell signal had a minimum
you just have to get out of the position
whether you want to get short or not but
honestly I think you would have been
stopped out here that you wouldn't even
had to make that decision and then when
this signal kicks
off you can you you can take it and and
ride
it okay again this is a one minute
chart uh you know this is a little early
you know you got to buy here okay yeah
it did kind of work out a little bit and
you got a sell here nice sell and a nice
move down you know bonds these last few
weeks have been uh very very good
trading markets you know you can make a
if you're positioned right you can make
uh some really nice trades and and rack
it up really early in the
day uh what is
this okay that one okay it's a little
bit different this again it's a bond
chart this is July 1st yeah you got a
Buy Signal here you know it moved up a
little bit maybe maybe came down stopped
you out I don't know before shooting
back
up you know but then what happens you
know a little bit later boom you get a
nice sell here again you know 174 24
down to uh you know 174 o so again are
you willing to take a little bit of risk
like this you know if you're getting
stopped out if you got to stop right
here I don't know if you how much room
you're giving it but you right around
the corner you're looking at this next
trade now I know some people will say oh
I see works great after you know you
have a losing trade take take the next
trade
well you know if you're doing that does
it increase
your your odds I don't I don't think so
I think you really should be sticking to
every single trade um I mean you could
finesse it you could add it into your
style of
trading and maybe find better entries
but I mean I won't get into that I'm
just for today I'm just talking about
the indicator in general Dax okay you
know Dax for a lot of people is is is a
market that drives them up the wall
because it moves super fast and fortunes
are are one and lost in this market and
you know but again it's same thing you
know it's Dax it's an eight range chart
I'm looking at the same things I'm
looking at the surges in Delta you know
made a move higher boom you get sell
here and it's it's a nice move down you
get to buy here yeah you maybe you could
have got something out you know but it
starts coming down like this you're
looking to get out for a scratch you're
not looking for it to stop you out you
get a buy up here again it's a move what
would you rather take would you rather
take a buy like this or a sell like this
you know after a move up you could have
two choices you know someone puts a gun
to your head okay decide what you going
to which trade you want to take after a
move from you know 9330 up to 9365 do
you want to get you want to take this
trade you want to take this trade I
would I would take this trade more so
than I would take this trade yeah you
might get a breakout but more often than
not you're just going to get the market
falling over again
again uh what is this Dax okay it's a
little bit more
choppier and you know we're sort of in
this area here it's kind of a range
range area start to break out of it
increase in Delta boom boom boom boom
and it shoots up quite
nicely uh another Dax chart I'm just
going to finish up with some Dax charts
here you know this one it didn't work um
you know again we came into a low
bounced up start coming back down again
you know again is capitulation you could
read it do that now here this we got
another sell signal it's a little bit
higher than where it was earlier but the
move is is a much smoother move
down so you know this one you probably
would have got stopped out on but you
could have you know whatever loss here
you get back on on this nice winter here
there's another Dax chart again you know
this is this is that move there you know
you make the big move down bounce up a
little bit start coming down again and
on the way back up you got a nice move
to cover for
it again you know are you willing to
take this risk this to capture this move
I I I think you should be willing to
do okay this is the last chart uh for
the day again it's a nice beautiful
chart you know people say oh you cherry
pick these charts well you know what if
you think so just download the indicator
throw it on your charts you'll see a lot
that are beautiful you'll see some that
are average and some that are crummy
okay but you know again I I I've showed
you times where it doesn't work I've
showed you times where it does
work and yeah this this is a nice one
you know if if anybody's traded for a
long time and you've traded Dax you know
what how crazy that market is uh someone
told me one of my users told me you know
in London they they call the Dax the
Widowmaker and I could understand that
and I I traded it for a while and you
know I was very successful with it for a
few months and then one day it
everything went pair shape and you know
a lot of what I had made I gave back to
the markets in in afternoon so you know
it's a can be a tough Market to trade
but you know this a market where you
could crank out some nice moves again
you know if you can get in and out of a
market pretty
quick honestly there's not as much risk
but you know that that's what you want
you want to be able to go in and out
with you know with your profits so
here's a nice buy you know starting to
move up okay yeah I don't know maybe you
maybe get stopped out here s of hanging
around around here then shoots up
kicking yourself if you got stopped out
you got a nice move up but here right at
this High you got a nice sell there's no
reason not to take this you know this is
what you want this is you know if there
was a textbook example of the sell
that's it right here and it's Market
makes a nice move
lower okay so you know again just read
it rate one of the problems that many
Traders face is not trading with Market
generated information what that means is
they trade with indicators that take
price and mathematically massage it into
something that's easy for them to
understand you know sell when the
oscillator crosses the zero line you
know or you know we're trading above a
level of 80 that means that you know
you're you're overbought and you should
look to to sell I mean that's not you
know that's not really
taking uh you know good trades you're
just you know reacting to something else
you're not you're not necessarily
thinking Delta surge takes Market
generated information and shows you
what's happening when one side is
showing their strength you know I showed
you what it looks like on bar charts but
honestly I think it really works best on
orderflow charts so you can digest you
know what's actually happening in the
market as opposed to just trading with a
chart that you got no clue as to what's
happening again it's it's a tool right
the Delta surge is a tool you know it's
think of it like a hammer you you you're
going to build a house you need a hammer
you can't build the whole house with
just a hammer it's a tool I mean some
people good Traders can take it and
develop it into something that you know
yeah they probably can turn it into a
trading system I'm not saying you can't
but at its basic level what I'm giving
to you is know how I used it in my
trading for years and you know I know
somebody will take it and you one of the
reason why I put it out there so so
people can have it and work with it and
hopefully you know they can turn it into
something and come back to me and say
hey you know what thanks for that
indicator this is how I'm using it and
you know then I I get something in
return in that sense so even though it's
out there for free you know I can do get
something you know pay it forward so to
speak so hopefully you know someone will
come back to me in the future and say
yeah this is what I was able to do with
it and look at it it's amazing thank you
and you know it's win-win for both of
us it's again it's not a red light green
light trading system system
if you want that then it's not for you
because that's not trading you know you
have to be able to make decisions in
life and if you can't make the decisions
in trading then you probably shouldn't
be trading and once you realize that you
know trading is about making decisions
then you'll become a better
Trader you know people ask me lots of
times you how can I become a better
Trader well the best way is to
understand what's happening in the
market you know you can't make good
trading decisions if you don't
understand why things are happening
happening in the
market
if you know you go go to the library you
say go to the bookstore bookstores don't
exist I don't know if librar still
exist or you know go to Amazon and and
get the books on trading biographies you
know and read all the major you know
read the biographies of the major
Traders as successful Traders you
they're successful because they
understand what makes the market
move you know they don't all trade the
same way you could read Market Wizards
you got 20 traders in there each person
has a different way of trading you know
so don't think that you know there's one
right way there's one wrong way I mean
there's a lot of wrong ways but there's
also a lot of right ways so you know the
Delta surge is putting it out there so
you know hopefully you can you know
learn something take it away from it and
you know learn to become a
better a better
Trader okay so you like I said you know
if you stuck around to the end here you
can down I'll tell you how to download
it for free from my webbsite you can
download it if you go to the following
web address www. orderflows
docomo index okay honestly it's a bit of
a mouthful uh let me see if I can you
know honestly you can probably I'll try
and change it but for now this is the
website I'll probably put a link to it
on my website so it's a bit easier to
find just go to my website orderflows
decom and look for Delta
sech it should be very easily to find I
want to
put it out there make it a little bit
easier I know this is a bit of a
mouthful for a lot of people but you
know that's what it is if you want to
type it in you know the page is there
you can just go in there and go to the
bottom of the page you know all the
instructions are there
so you know thanks everyone for watching
this presentation to learn more about
the trading software that I use in this
presentation and how you can profit from
orderflow Trading visit my main website
www. orderflows
to my YouTube channel I post a lot of
videos up um almost every day you know
time permitting and you know hopefully
you've learned something today that you
can apply to your trading again you know
check out the indicator just go to this
website address and you can download it
for free I'll try to put it in in the
link below to this video on YouTube so
you can just uh click on it so thanks
all and see you on the inside bye-bye